please welcome someone that i really
consider to be a phenomenal human being
i'm getting to know him a little bit and
i'm falling deeper in love every single
minute please welcome the wonderful
unique kind brilliant funny and totally
inspiring jonathan van ness
[Applause]
[Applause]
jonathan and i are talking about i just
posted another video
uh about your
product that has truly changed my life
and i just am out there on mountaintops
and
roaring about it everywhere can i just
say that like so not to name drop right
at the very beginning of our interview
but when i became friends with michelle
kwan it took me
it took me like two full years to like
not be star struck even as we were
friends so even though we're getting to
know each other even though i've gotten
to see you in real life like several
times and we're like when i saw that
video this is like off script everyone
like we're i mean it look like i'm
actually getting like emotion like and i
like it like i was just i can't
i just have loved you for such a long
time and to see my products that i've
just worked on for so long and to see
you use it i just it really
yeah i like i i actually have a tear i
don't know if it's the sleep deprivation
for being on book tour or if it's no but
it's uh but it is just it really meant
so much to me and thank you for lifting
up people so much it means so much
thank you
thank you so much thank you for saying
that
[Applause]
um all right i would i've been reading
this book it's so beautiful so what is
your advice for people actively dating i
think that
what is so important for dating and
whether you're in a relationship or not
i feel like it's our relationship with
ourself
is what is so important because even if
you are looking to be in relationship
with someone
like we always are going to come back to
our relationships with ourselves and
yoga this one time we learned that like
we all have this like invisible magnet
that's inside of us it's either like
positively or like negatively charged
you know and i think that when you're
working on yourself it's going to charge
that magnet in such a way that the
person you're meant to be with is going
to like vibe towards you anyway so you
really can't lose by like investing in
yourself and in your relationship with
yourself anyway okay this is why i asked
you this question
okay
body image i really love the body image
chapter um
what's a good way to
again kind of speak to ourselves or get
comfortable in ourselves for who we are
and how we are yeah so in the in my
essay about uh learning to accept my
beautiful body and um
i'm thinking a lot about the term body
neutrality and i think that for so long
like we just our value doesn't need to
come from our bodies period we are so
worth being loved and celebrated and and
being and having our humanity um
uh
what's that word validated
we are allowed to have our humanity
validated not based on how we look but
just because we are here because we are
human it's not an external thing and
then the other thing i think about and i
talk about in this book and i talked
about my last book a little bit is um
this idea of it's like parts therapy
like we are parts we all have this
multitude of parts of our personalities
and when there's a part of ourselves
that's like really really like fixated
or bothered by or like worried about
this like way that we look it's okay for
you to be in relationship with yourself
like with that part and be like you know
and i actually did this in this chapter
it's like what's going on for me it all
boiled down to this bowflex commercial
ah
these bowflex commercials when i was
like 500 and i was like mom when am i
going to have my abdominals when am i
going to look like that i remember being
like five so such a little kid seeing
all of these messages that we see in the
media um that makes you feel like you're
meant to look a certain way or be a
certain way and so that's a lot to
unlearn because when we're all just like
kids out in the world we're like
learning there's so much to see and then
all of a sudden you become an adult and
you're like why am i
why don't i like this you know and also
like why do i have to be brave for
liking how i look
why can't we celebrate how we are i i i
that's why i think like body positivity
and the the emphasis that we put on
people who we deem to be body positive
like we are all worth celebrating no
matter how you look and and so i think
we got to like decouple that
assistance
[Music]